on a que toutes celles qui va jouer avec
nous il y aura 100 500 milles série noro
un casque audio le dernier album des
tribal king tribal king vous rappeler
est un pèse personne et un kilo de kiwis
bonjour ma chérie comment ça va comment
tu t'appelles ghislaine chrislaine
j'adore et là doriz les chattes
j'adore chris le mans series l'aisne
rizlène comme mir l'aisne mais sauf que
tu en as tu remplaces l'ami retard du
riz et ça fait rire et voilà tout
simplement magique ma chérie tu fais
quoi dans la vie ça c'est dur aussi
c'est dur c'est tel quel beau métier
quel beau métier auxiliaire
puéricultrice j'étais auxiliaire de
puériculture mais aussi pendant des
années les prix ça mais j'ai roulé ma
bosse moi je te le dit henry z à ma
chérie confiance est un mec t'es marié
et ayant en outre compliquer haïti de
qu'est ce qui se passe alors des mois
que les noms comme elle s'appelle nice à
vanessa nice à nice a ouais ça très bien
ma chérie on va jouer ensemble alors
attention tu est confiné avec ton mec
ouais comment il s'appelle anthony quoi
ton peuple utilité au bout du rouleau
avec mais là non plus être tout le temps
comme ça tout tenté doit d'aurec ton mec
tu vois que ça gueule toute la journée
de ta sacoche état que d'une loi
longueur d'année la taquinerie et ses
rires mais ferme un peu ta gueule
ferme ta gueule anthony qua non mais
sans rigoler ça va bon bah très bien
énorme et sans immolé tu vois la femme
de castagne elle m'a encore appelé ce
matin alors en vue de meilleurs
graphismes un peu ta gueule casse la
gueule
le même jour la ola la pêche iéna bon
match on va jouer au bois droite on va
jouer boiboite tu peux gagner jusqu'à sa
vie dont j'ai ici les boîtes huit boîtes
qui sont là d'accord je vais les prendre
près de moi et ma chérie on va jouer tu
va choisir une boîte à la fin d'accord
tu vas en d'éliminer cette et la
dernière qui restera ce sera ta boîte
d'accord ma chérie d'amour tu peux
gagner en tous sens 500 euros 1000 euros
5000 euros un casque audio
le dernier album de tribal king
normalement on avait un extrait d tribal
king mais on réagit ni n'ont pas encore
mis un pèse personne et un kilo de kiwi
d'accord donc tu as quatre très beau
cadeau un état quatre cadeaux pas mal
mais pas ouf
ma chérie je ne pourrais pas tricher une
car si sous contrôle d'huissier tu auras
un moment à tout moment
l'intervention du banquier merzoug
blanchard pourra m'appeler à tout moment
pour te proposer un deal à ok mais
rejoue plus à intervenir à tout moment
je vais les demandé aux équipes de me
mettre une musique engagée la bête
probable qu'une musique de suspense tout
de suite on est parti pour les boîtes
aux joues tous ensemble au jeu des
bruyères les parents sa mère joue
blanchard apparaître après quelle boîte
élimine tueur premier l'a déjà déjà je
vais demander je vais te demander quelle
boîte tu prends toi quelle boîte tu
gardes auraient tout de suite les
numéros 8
donc c'est quoi ouais la numéro 8 on va
dire que c'est ta boîte
voilà la numéro 8 7 à boîte c'est comme
ça 8 c'est 8,7 à bord d'accord ta boîte
et les là on ne sait pas ce qu'il ya
dedans il peut avoir mis leurs hôtes pas
avoir 5000 euros il peut avoir les
traits walking qui peut avoir tout ce
que tu ma chérie s'il ya maintenant sept
boîtes qui sont là d'accord
attention laquelle et diminuant 1er
c'est parti et envoyer une musique les
chéris enrichi merci il ya une personne
aurait dit donc que c'est une personne
qui a renvoyé il dit
elle dort aouicha stop l'année merci ma
chérie tu élimines quelle boîte numéro 2
la numéro un le numéro deux et dans la
numéro deux tu viens de perdre
tu viens de perdre ma chérie
le casque audio ah bah tu as perdu
le casque audio ça va donc y tient sur
un an tous les autres beaux cadeaux je
rappelle qu'il ya 100 euros 500 euros
1000 euros 5000 euros le dernier album
des tribal king un pèse personne est
inquiet autres qui vous à wisches à en
régie est ce qu'on peut entendre une
petite musique ça fait quinze fois que
j'ai eu deux mandats
elle dort laquelle
laquelle tu relèves maintenant
la numéro 6 la numéro 6 intentions la
numéro 6 c'est parti
la numéro 6 tu pourra demander l'avis
des chroniqueurs à toi moi je rappelle
que merzoug blanchard notre banc qui
jouera tu as perdu un très beau cadeau
matière qu est ce que tu perds un pèse
personne
alors pour l'instant est pour l'instant
on n'est pas les droits sans faute
reese rennes pour l'instant un sans
faute attention rappelle que tu as
choisi la boîte numéro 8 c'est à boîte
lezennes quelle boîte élimine tout
maintenant
demandez l'avis à casal dit non alors
loyer alors non une bonne journée mon
avis je chat noir mais ça ne doit pas
lui ah oui je t'en supplie palus a on a
le banquet merzouk héberge blanchard qui
est arrivé bonjour merzouk bonjour un
clic
[Rires]
alors que je suis pas ici elle est
désarmée 11 merde tu sais pourquoi je
vous appelle où tu sais pas du tout et
bien sûr à cause du coût schilb on ne
peut pas de couper je veux c'est un
kidnapping wind du bonheur
les moteurs mais non c'est pas bouder
c'est bien sous de longs ça vous diriez
vous à l'heure dans leur sens alors
merci pour l'instant riesen à éliminer
deux boîtes vraiment elle a illuminé le
pèse-personne elle a éliminé le casque
audio donc les deux cadeaux les plus
pauvres pour l'instant ça se passe très
bien pour il n ya peut-être une boîte à
5000 euros peut-être que la boîte
qu'elle a choisi ses 5000 euros est ce
que tu veux lui proposer un deal pour
l'instant ou rien du tout
pour l'instant je propose de continuer
sur sa lancée
merci à tout à l'heure vers vous mais
renoue bon état on viendra tout à
l'heure rizlène quelle boîte élimine tu
maintenant la numéro 7
la numéro 7 attention pour l'instant
rizlène tout se passe bien pour toi tout
se passe très très bien pour toi
rizlène la numéro 7 la cendre via l'a7
rizlène c'est de l'argent tu viens dans
des hayes
c'est une boîte a écrit je rappelle
qu'il ya une boîte à son héros une boîte
à samson une boîte à ninon bolt à 110,2
et tu vient d'éliminer la boîte à 100
euros
pour l'instant ça se passe très très
très très bien il te reste quatre boîtes
à éliminer et tu gardes toujours ta
boite c'est la mi temps
les n élimine une nouvelle boîte à tout
instant merzoug blanchard pour être
proposé un deal
la numéro 1 la numéro 1
maïga soldats
ah oui je sentais bien
les usa s'en passait la main non risen
ma chérie bon tu aura peut-être d'autres
beaux cadeaux mais rizlène tu viens de
perdre le dernier album des tribal king
colonisation à l'effet baltique c'était
façon sexy en régie dont ils vont pas
tomber
il te reste 4 aux boîtes donc te reste
quatre boîtes alors
l'a3 et l'a4 l'a5 et celle que tu as
choisi depuis le départ la 8e' reste
la boîte à 500 euros la boîte à 1000
euros la boîte à 5000 euros il reste un
kilo de kiwi pour vous dire c'est très
très très très chaude ce qui se passe là
reven quelle boîte est limité
[Musique]
le numéro 5
la numéro ce aussi risqué
la numéro avant que jour la doubler en 5
n'est pas encore ouverte
est-ce que merzouk doigts ça indique à
proposer à risen merci alors ce que je
propose
harry's l'aide c'est d'échanger sa boîte
contre un autre îlot de boîte
excusez moi vous êtes banque et depuis
combien de temps je suis celui qui
nettoie la banque
[Musique]
pour l'instant la garder ça va elle
refuse votre proposition revenait tout à
l'heure merci merci
attention elle a choisi d'éliminer la
boîte numéro 5
oh la la la boîte numéro 5
risen le shérif non ça va ça va ça va ça
part c'est une belle somme mais tu perds
cette somme 500 euros
il y a toujours la boîte un minot il ya
toujours la boîte à 1000 euros
il y a le kilo de kiwis il reste le 3
boîte tu as choisi la voie de l héroïne
j'ai une proposition
vas-y eux proposent d'acheter sa boîte à
600 euros donc ils te donnent 600 euros
tout de suite entendu qu'il qu'il mois
600 euros aux propos aucune proposition
européenne se le dise qu'il te reste la
boîte à milon la boîte à 5000 et le kilo
de kiwis donc tu as deux boîtes au
dessus et tactile aux kiwis qui serait
une catastrophe
je te le dis je ne pourrais pas tricher
en plus parce que là on est sérieux
ryssen ma chérie est-ce que tu acceptes
la proposition à 600 euros de bouder ou
est-ce que tu me dis non j'ai une boîte
ami j'ai une boîte à 5000 le brouillard
en six manches et non c'est merzouki
très tôt est-ce que tu acceptes la
proposition de merzuk blanchard à 6 ans
sachant que c'est du kiwi qui vient du
mexique
alors tu peux partir avec 600 euros tout
de suite très zen ou bien tous les
banquiers oui je dis oui dit non tu me
dis non non non je crois en ma bonne
étoile
je sais qu'en ce moment voilà je ne suis
confiné chez moi je veux aller au bout
de ce jeu je veux tenter les 5000 au tas
de bois au dessus stade une boîte hamid
une boîte à saint gilles et à le kilo ki
moon que toi tu es merzouk blanchard
thiopet t'a proposé 600 euros
qu'est ce que tu sens
mais bien sûr que refusent les 600 euros
de bouder les rejouer il reviendra dans
un instant quand il restera tout de
boîtes peut-être pour te faire une
nouvelle proposition
merci mr roux blanchard notre banc qui
devrait très vite vers joue gros chars
bien sûr de mère avignonnaise et de fer
marocains on embrasse
risen il te reste trois boîtes a choisi
la boîte numéro 8 pour l'instant
toujours laquelle lui diminué entre l'a3
et l'a4
[Musique]
éliminerez laqué qu'à notre coach tu
peux remonter peut-être
avis aux chroniqueurs à un chroniqueur
tu vois tu demanderas l'avait acquis
sophie
moi impact yves mange aurélie minella 4
mais je veux pas être responsable et
surtout je veux pas maître de mon argent
je marche vraiment m ça m'embêterait me
faire taire on voit là tandis que j'ai
engagé ouais numéro s'il vous plaît
madame étant je sens bien la 3 et la vie
c'est comme risen juste par intérim agit
pour la numéro 4
venez me la numéro 4 s'il vous plaît là
c'est un moment très important
dn il te restera ensuite plus que de
bois
il reste pour l'instant la boîte à 5000
euros la voix thani d'euros et la boîte
avec un kilo de kiwi de 6,6 la clac
c'est la boîte avec oki l'oki oui
c'est magnifique à ce que ces gagnants
parmi nos 1000 euros quoi qu'il arrive
ce sera une excellente nouvelle pour toi
je rappelle côté auxiliaire
puéricultrice
tu habites ou grise l'aisne
d'accord ma chérie
je vais tout de suite te dire ce qu'il y
avait dans la boîte numéro 4
sachez chez vous que je découvre moi
même ce qu'il ya dans les bois vraiment
je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya peut-être que
la boîte c'est la boîte à 5000 euros et
je peux rien dire
[Musique]
m
rezaï
oui
avant qu'on découvre qu'il ya dans la
boîte numéro 4
est ce que tu veux écouter une autre
proposition de mr ou mme blanchard
d'entre eux manquaient
merzouk merzouki m'entends tu es oui
très bien les zouk
est-ce que vous avez une nouvelle
proposition à ferrari zen ou pas encore
alors m'apprend marc promis ma
proposition est la suivante
rizlène écoutez moi dire qui je voue
rachet enfin je nous vous machine à ce
que je la sens la patate visite abri
nous vous rappelons la boîte à lille
tous auront jamais les 12 euros 1000 12
euros je vais voir ces navires est dans
la boîte numéro 4 les haines ou tu me
dis je ne vois pas ce qu'il ya dans la
boîte numéro quatre et je prends les
milles 12 euros demeurent zouk blanchard
ou bien tu sois dit de continuer et de
tenter
les 5000 euros
dn
est-ce que tu as peut-être appropriation
de mercy
position c'est une belle somme 1000
euros en même temps pas mal
attention attention elle a eu beaucoup
de chance depuis le début rizlène et
peut-être qu'à voir partir avec les 5000
euros ouais et 1,4 kg au prix lui absent
- à quoi l'installer sincèrement mais je
pense que tu vas mortes et chance et
rien qu'à elle refuse la première de mer
dom l'ancien maître par un nasri mais
chérie je vais vous montrer tout de
suite ce qu'il y avait
dans la boîte nous y aurons katherine
legge haute a proposé 1012
au 1012 euros comme tu l'as dit c'est à
peu près ton salaire alors je dis pas
que tout est perdu
parce que quoi qu'il arrive voilà il
reste trois boîtes une amie lunas hamid
et united qu'il aux kiwis celle que tu
as choisi là c'est celle qu'on va
éliminer sais c'est que tu ne pourras
plus gagné
here is then depuis le début ça s'est
très très bien passé pour toi
rizlène les kiwis tu vient d'éliminer
oui
aurait peut-être dû accepter la
proposition de winners ou blanchard
parce que je sais que en ce moment on
est confiné et que font manger des
choses saines et tu viens de perdre ici
ma chérie il te reste est rentable tu
restes tu ta boîte samoa de 0,8 à porter
chance depuis le début ou la 3 ya
peut-être les 5000 euros dans ta boîte
la boîte numéro 8 dans un instant il y
aura une nouvelle proposition de notre
banque émerge blanchard peut-être que tu
va repartir avec 5000 euros en tout cas
quoi qu'il arrive tu repartiras au moins
avaient pilon on va se retrouver dans un
instant pour le jeu des boîtes de la
maison a tout de suite petites bottes si
vous nous rejoignez on joue au jeu des
bois voir sur ces vies
ce soir chez ba ba et ce soir shebab à
son prestige
il ya énormément de pression énormément
de pression pour celles qui aiment le
riz celles qui aiment la laine
celle qui se prénomme rizlène une pincée
dry un poil de laine que vous avez une
personne magnifique auxiliaire
puéricultrice
ayant influencé qui la gonfle et un
enfant qu'elle chérit tendrement
lezennes elle avait huit boîtes au
départ elle a éliminé toutes les boîtes
pour ne garder
c'est incroyable que les boîtes qui
contenaient les sommes les plus
importantes
la boîte à 5000 euros et la boîte à milo
son choix
c'est toute une portée vers la boîte
numéro 8 qui l'a amenée jusqu'ici
bravo les conseils
deux personnes qui ne pensait qu'à une
chose
l'envoyer dans la boîte
[Musique]
les aime jeunes a su écouter que ton
coeur d'une a su écouter que ce qu'il y
avait dans ta tête
est ce qu'il y avait dans ta tête était
beau comme du riz en cause m
oui on n'a pas trop d'annonceurs en soit
à voir avec le confinement ici je
faisais de glisser des marques d'accor
est elle un peu gros et les autres
banques et les zouk blanchard va te
faire une proposition
il te reste la boîte numéro 3 et la
boîte numéro 8 laquelle des situe dans
le fait déjà
pour l'instant tu as porté chance ou
toujours moi je ne sais pas ce qu'il en
est vraiment je ne sais pas mais la [ __ ]
pour l'instant et vignal et je ne sais
pas après voilà tu fais ce que tu veux
qu'on puisse pas d'influencé merzouk
blanchard notre banquier est-ce que vous
avez une proposition à faire un reset
alors écoutez moi bien mener vers
d'autres pas plus de france est merzoug
thomas j'ai une proposition en
proposition est la suivante à les hummer
vous ozy days 1200 euros plus ce n'est
pas fini smartphone
lise de soirée tous un smartphone
exactement
alors où vous me dites je prends la
proposition de mr ou mme blanchard ou
bien non je garde la boîte numéro 8
jusqu'au bout
evo tentent de gagner plus avec les 5000
euros rizlène proposition est
insuffisante
apparemment les gens ne sont pas
contents de votre opposition berthou
wallon oui mais la charge ou series et
qui m'intéresse est d'accord avec à la
négo blog dégaine ses visées sans plus
écoutez moi bien riziers vous avez le
choix
mais moi ce que je vous propose c'est du
concret c'est très abstrait c'est 1200
euros sur plus un smartphone ça c'est ce
qui sur ma votre poche
à vous de réfléchir mais le board et de
manquer c'est un banquier il est devenu
un super g mais j'aimerais par les
arbitres rizlène ce qui est sûr je la
mets de côté la boîte numéro trois sur
vous prenez lavit léger ton régressa
donc on garde la boîte numéro donc vous
pensez que dans la boîte numéro 8 hidan
et 5000 euros
cette boîte qui n'ont rien c'est ce que
va gagner rizlène dans un instant vous
avez donc le choix entre eux
cette boîte est la proposition de
merzouga blanchard banquier qui a
traversé les les plus grandes crises
directement
il a traversé la crise de 29
j ai d'être il était il a traversé la
crise de 2007
et la clé des coiffeurs
thriller et conférences merci les riches
quoi je rappelle la proposition du
banquier merzoug blanchard 1200 euros
plus un smartphone ou bien sera jeudi à
1h
je rajoute une invitation dans le public
de tpb lorsque ça reprendra vous et
votre fille votre mari ce qu'elle en a à
[ __ ] vols habités quoi qu'il arrive
oui quel plus en plus mesquin merci
ouvert plus de pedra prodcast humains
confirmés descazeaux et les vidéos l'eau
je l'attends merci merci merci
allez les haines une fois une réponse
est on valide
[Musique]
maiden ou partez avec les 1200 euros
plus le smartphone ou me dit non je
garde ma boîte je pense que dans ma
boîte ya plus
je pense que dans la boîte il ya les 100
kg
jaffa qui vous avez une boîte à 1000
euros et une boîte à 5000 euros qui vous
reste donc façon dans cette boîte yahoo
millions ou 5 me dont l'une speyside
visait vous refuser la proposition du
banquier
pourtant il a les yeux revolver brisbane
je vais découvrir ce qu'il ya dans votre
boîte rizen s'il ya des 5000 euros ce
serait exceptionnel qu'est ce que vous
feriez avec les 5000 euros rizla n'y a
plus de choses franchement j'ai encore
des amis à une petite fille avec vous
et j'étais ravi son mari
ja au pire des cas il ya mille euros
dans cette boîte parce que les chats
magnifique non personnes 1200 récupère
bien ce qu'a fait on espère tous cas les
5 millions dans cette boîte
risen
si vous nous rejoignez aux jauges des
bois bois on est à la maison
rizlène à éliminer toutes les bonnes
boîtes il lui restait une boîte a mis
une boîte à saint denis où une boîte à
saint meen une boîte à nîmes je n'ai pas
encore découvert ce qu'il ya dans les
boîtes et elle a choisi la boîte numéro
dit le banquier merzouk verlan charme
vient de faire une proposition de 1200
euros plus un smartphone elle a refusé
cette proposition
je vais tout de suite regardé ce qu'il
ya dans la boîte numéro
[Musique]
allez
réserver
je vous demandais une dernière fois
[Musique]
est-ce que
vous refusez la proposition de berjou
blanchard
qui est je le rappelle 1200 euros
[Musique]
j'ai ce qui est meilleur est-ce que je
tape une dernière fois rizlène
si je tape une dernière fois c'est que
c'est terminé on part sur la boîte 8 on
refuse toutes les autres propositions
à des jeux
déçu c'est donc cette boîte et cette
somme comme a gagné rizlène nature
rizlène
c'est où 5000 ou 1000 euros
ali
[Musique]
mais
rogge
jane eyre du ferro
déjà des héros
[Musique]
risen
vous avez gagné aujourd'hui
grâce aux boîtes
vous avez gagné ruelle
[Musique]
milon
c'est bien et on va vérifier quand même
regarder droit dans la 3 dans la 3g
tessin dans la 3c 5000 euros ça s'est
bien passé jusqu'au bout j'y avais pas
ce qu'ils avaient dans les boîtes
vraiment mairie 16es 1000 euros pour toi
quand même assez bien tu sais c'est
quand même génial
elle a été servie table parce que m
t'avais les deux des deux meilleurs
soient pas la fin et franchement je suis
très heureux pour toi tu gagnes 1000
euros aujourd'hui surtout en ce moment
ça va faire du bien continue ce que tu
fais je te fais des normes bisous 1000
euros plus tu viens tu es pmp quand tu
veux si je te fais un énorme bisou
merciris lettres d'avoir est avec nous
1000 euros pour toi emile auront quand
même c'est bon mais très bien quelle
séquence
merci chéri verser les aides